this morning on the dish atlanta
restaurateur justin anthony he wasn't a
trained chef but he always thought the
food of his native south africa might be
a big hit in this country
and he was right expanding to a handful
of eateries in atlanta
then the pandemic hit and he turned much
of his attention to feeding his
community
prepping and delivering meals to
frontline healthcare workers
at hospitals near his biltong bar one of
those eateries
just before that turn of events i had
the chance to sit down with anthony as
we all used to do
and enjoy a culinary tour of his
homeland
so welcome to beef jerky and booze i
love it here at biltong bar
justin anthony brings the street food of
his native south africa
to atlanta bolton is different than beef
jerky and then it's air dried
kind of like a dry aged steak so right
now we've got our traditional right here
okay
this one right here is peri-peri so the
it's going to be spicy coming for that
the cured meat is a south african staple
brought by the dutch four centuries ago
what's interesting is that
literally on every street corner every
butcher you go into
there's just bolton everywhere but it's
very much
only exist in south africa and
she says south africa's unique cuisines
are a direct result of its makeup south
africa has 11 11 official languages it's
the same thing with the food so you've
got french portuguese
dutch german english indian malaysian
and mediterranean influences so like
there's so much going on
if somebody asked you now what is south
african cuisine
in a sentence what would you say south
african cuisine
is it's a fusion of i hate using the
word fusion basically it's like by
taking your taste buds on safari
anthony would eventually bring that
safari to america
but it was sports that brought him here
almost 25 years ago
i moved to atlanta back in 96
just before the olympics and i moved
here to actually play professional
soccer
so that's how i ended up in atlanta and
unfortunately
or maybe fortunately for all of us
soccer didn't work
yeah i had a knee injury and i was
struggling to play at the level that i
wanted to play at
so i made a conscious decision that i
was going to retire uncertain about
what career might be next anthony had an
epiphany
in the mid to late 90s there were a lot
of south africans moving to atlanta and
i was like you know what i've been
always been passionate about food and
wine my parents are chefs and i kind of
grew up around it and so
i was like i'm gonna open up a south
african pub restaurant
and everyone thought i was crazy because
it's not that easy to do
this was 97 1997 there was like
no such thing as a south african
restaurant so literally i went from
being a professional soccer player to
being
a waiter at a restaurant just kind of
learning the business all of these
dishes have been a staple since day one
anthony who's an only child convinced
his parents diane and derek
to leave johannesburg and join him here
in the states
i mean now that i think about it it was
terrifying but
i mean you know we did what we had to do
right
to make ourselves happy and to be with
justin
that's what parents do isn't it together
they crafted a menu that encompasses the
many flavors and spices of home
in 1998 they open what they believe was
the first
south african restaurant in the u.s 10
degrees south
which is south africa's location from
the tropic of capricorn
let's dig in we share dishes like
chicken curry
perry perry chicken and calamari what
was it really like
in the early days of first of all trying
to come up with
this but then also working with your son
it's a different
thing to work with family than working
with other people
i think it worked well i mean we were
just so busy
trying to make things work and we were
doing everything i mean every single one
of us knew how to bartend
serve be in the kitchen all of us
now along with 10 degrees south anthony
operates
four restaurant concepts in atlanta
including biltong bar
yebo beach house and cape dutch every
time i eat curry or perry perry i start
sweating
but he calls 10 degrees south the
mothership with foods at his other spots
stemming from it you notice i'm not
being shy i'm just reaching for it yeah
i think it is go through
in south africa we have a saying get
stuck in
that's it just take the whole thing
and the right way to eat the floor yeah
just take it out the shell
right chew the shell and suck it so you
get the taste and so you can really get
and you get the real taste well i
wouldn't say it's the right way
well i mean it's his way
did you ever imagine when your son was
playing soccer
that this would become the future no
i thought that he was going to do sports
psychology
and that was it and instead
a family business
[Applause]
the anthony family has hosted a
veritable who's who
from morgan freeman and robert de niro
to aaron rodgers
and lebron james which dessert am i
about to try
it's called a lot this is the
this is the lebron james dessert is what
somebody who's an nba fan would say
it's a a riff if you will of a
traditional south african dessert called
malba pudding
oh my gosh even without the ice cream
would be
delicious yes ron james famously ate
i think seven or eight of them before
dinner yeah why not really play for the
heat they were in town
anthony says it's his sports background
that team philosophy and work ethic he
had on the field
which played a big part of building
success
in the restaurant industry there's not
such thing as an easy business you want
to be a successful athlete
you better work hard you want to be a
successful business owner you better
work hard yeah the harder you work the
luckier you get nothing happens
easy you have to work for it to know
that you came here to play soccer
and you've created a family business of
restaurants
for you what's that like you know
sometimes i have to pinch myself
it's kind of the american dream and the
name of the restaurant group true story
brands and he says that's because it is
a true story that they were able to
build this here in america the
american dream i really miss our dishes
you hate to sit there
i know it's so close like that
pre-pandemic yeah